what's going on everybody welcome to
another monte carlo and python tutorial
video
in this video we're just going to keep
expanding on the last thing that we're
doing and that's building our monte
carlo simulator
so scrolling down to the bottom uh this
is the percent roi that we really need
to beat
but i'm going to go ahead and make this
just an even one just because
we're probably going to have a lot of
things that beat it but aren't
necessarily
the better than it right so if you
recall when we did a short sample size
of even the the strategy that returned
a 0.865 uh
roi that was with one million samples
but even at 100 000 samples we were
finding
vastly changing amounts between you know
maybe plus 100 000 or minus 100
or heck i think it was even greater than
that it was like plus 800 minus 800
000 or something like that so anyway
let's go ahead
and continue on here
what we want to do is if this is the
case
um we do care about it the other thing i
want to go ahead and add is
we also want to know like the wager size
percent
because i think what we're going to do
is we're going to save because we did
say i think we yeah right down here
what we're going to do is we're going to
every time we find something we're going
to save that variable
and we're going to make this so we save
that variable to like a csv
or something like that so over time we
can build on it
and then eventually plot this stuff so
the first thing i want to do
is first let's make the variable we'll
call it
wager size percent that's equal to
this right here so i'm just going to cut
paste and then
copy this and paste that there so now we
have that
uh variable now if percent roi is
greater than one so if the return on
investment was greater than one what do
we want to do well what we're going to
do
is all of this and then we actually want
to save this stuff
so the first thing we should do is we
need to specify a save file
and that save file we're going to call
it oops
save file equals open you know this file
doesn't need to exist either it'll be
created
we're going to call it money carlo
um i guess we'll call it liberal
for now and the reason why we're going
to call it liberal is i think
one is a pretty small number and we're
only we're using a sample size that's
pretty small as well
and so eventually maybe we'll raise the
percent roi
or we'll raise this number and then
we'll call that
monte carlo conservative and we want to
open this anyways with the intention for
appending now we want to create the line
that we want to save
um this is not the best way to make it
make this file but that's okay save line
e equals we'll start with a new line
and then we'll add plus string version
of
percent roi uh right here
plus our comma plus
the string version of wager
size percent
plus the string
version of
wager count
with the final plus uh
comma g so the reason why i'm doing this
is this is just going to be our save
line it's going to start with a new line
and once this file starts i'll just
delete the first empty line
that way we're not dealing with any
empty lines anymore
uh string percent roi we have to convert
this stuff to a string in order to
concatenate everything otherwise you
can't you know you can't concatenate a
string in a
in it so that's the idea there
um and then at the very end we're using
that g because we're that's going to be
the color
of the scatter plot that we have so
we're going to be plotting
green because this was a um a positive
roi
so now let me take this oh no
okay let me take this
copy and we'll just paste this here
and make this l if roi
is less than negative one
we lost money everything else is the
same but we wanna
um this one will be colored red
when we chart it so
uh now i think we're all set
we just really wanted oh we're not all
set we need
we actually need to save this stuff so
save file
dot right save line
and then save file dot close
and i'm just gonna copy this come down
here
paste and that should be it so
when we run this what it should do is
begin saving this data to a file for us
so let's go ahead and save and run see
if we have any errors
before it looks like it's running
and i'll open up the file here
bring it over okay so here's our file
and again the only thing that we really
need to do is get rid of that empty line
so
do that do it quickly before you get all
screwed up with this if it prints out
more
but anyway as we can see here let me
move this over
this is the file and again it's saving
first
the percentage return on investment the
wager size percent
and then we have i think wager count
yeah then you've got
wager count how many wagers did you run
through to get there
and then the color of these plots that
we want them to be so
that's basically it uh you can see that
we've got a plus and a minus obviously
the minus is
red and the plus is green we haven't got
anybody else
since the initial but uh anyway
uh so now what you'd want to do is you
kind of want to let this run for a while
i would just let it run at least for
like 30 minutes or something so you can
actually have some data i'm still i
can't believe we haven't got like
anything else beginning to wonder if we
should
like make a counter and make sure this
is actually still running or something
um there we go finally okay so anyway so
we got some more
here we go updated so again minus three
red oh we got some more
um and so on so you get the point so
i would say you'd want to at least
populate this with 10 15
20 rows so just keep running it until
you have about 10 15
20 or more rows the more rows you add
the more data you have
uh the better this is going to work out
for you so i'm actually going to let
this run for quite a while
and stack up quite a few rows so anyways
stay tuned to the next video as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions
and until next time